[Musique]
ouagadougou un nom qui a toujours
raisonné pour moi comme la promesse d'un
beau voyage
ouagadougou la capitale du burkina faso
un pays situé au coeur de l'afrique de
l'ouest
dans la langue des mots si la langue de
l'ethnie majoritaire
dur qui la face aux signifie la patrie
des hommes intègres
et ben premier matin avec une grosse
chaleur à ouagadougou burkina faso il a
fait un sérieux me trouver une mobylette
au marché mais je crois je suis vraiment
dans le bon endroit il ya que ça
[Musique]
il ya 15 millions d'habitants au burkina
faso et je me demande s'il n'y a pas
autant de mobylette
d'ailleurs dans le centre de ouagadougou
un immense marché consacré entièrement
aux deux roues
bonjour bonjour je regarde un peu les
différents modèles il faut que je trouve
une mobylette mais j'ai besoin de
quelque chose de sérieux et une
mobylette d'occasion
il y en a plus là bas ça
d'accord ok je viens pour y faire un
tour
[Musique]
et je te dis mon avait fait ça fait
cinquante il faut que ça tienne la route
parce que si ça tient pas la route
moi je vous la ramène
il faut que je puisse rouler pendant
tous les jours tous les jours
focal démarrer sans problème
et un bon prix c'est tout comme
d'habitude quoi
alors ça va fonctionner un jour cela
ça donne de l'espoir peut-être à
d'autres tas d'autres modèles à montreux
ça c'est la peugeot afp johnny jolly
donc celle là elle est sophistiqué avec
[Musique]
la wii pour pas gratter à peinture très
bien ça c'est mais ça c'est d'occasions
voilà ce rang du marché
et comment ça se fait qu'on mange si tôt
parce que là il est il est huit heures
du matin et mangent déjà
mais ça mais ils vont ils vont pas
remanger à après midi
encore mais qu'est ce que c'est c'est
défense de la nature
ça c'est le petit déjeuner moi j'ai pris
un pauvre petit croissance mât d'un
ps en cas d'accord sanelli way a oublié
toutes les marques d'accor je suis un
spécialiste est d'accord et je peux
essayer voir si ça démarre
[Musique]
y'a pas de france
ils ont essayé il n'y a pas beaucoup de
place pour essayer
ça freine pas vraiment on va aller
serrer
attentionné s'est passé on va faire un
essai
asie on voit la route
on
il
[Musique]
j'ai enfin ma mobylette et je me lance
priorité
doublé
il fait chaud quasiment 40 degrés et je
suis bien le seul à porter un casque
ouagadougou est une ville plate
quadrillé de larges boulevards bruyant
et poussiéreux
premières sensations bizarrement je ne
suis pas impressionné par la circulation
autant que le penser
parce qu'ici tout le monde roule à la
même vitesse il suffit de suivre ce qui
nous entoure
en attendant de commencer mon voyage et
de quitter la capitale je m'arrête dans
une petite gargote histoire de sentir
l'air de la ville
ça
[Musique]
je vous en prie
bien sûr c'est la pause
ici vu de l'impact mais qu'en plus c'est
un peu mieux que vous faites quoi vous
vous êtes vous récupérez six jeunes
artistes d'accord ou les ans qui n'est
pas l'argent tôt ils enlèvent des ans
exige être d'accord moi je laisse pas
traîner dagenham a fait dix sculptures
d'accord mais je maintiens très tôt
dans l'étape du
salut bon je te suis
le temps je vais parce que j'arrive à
faire avec ça
oui
ça va
[Musique]
donc on va aller où on va aller faire la
récup
pipi dans tim adams ou les
c'est ça ton paradis c'est justement
c'est mon paradis et moins 15 morts en
même temps trésor ouais
moi mais comment tu fais pour apporter
sa ensuite si c'est pas beaucoup de
moi aussi la riaj est pas encore mis mon
sac donc on peut en mettre sûrement sur
montant d'eur
je suis très content que sur moi qu'il a
commencé à récupérer et qui aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une recette de tout bien
sûr au commencement mais disait fou et
aujourd'hui dieu merci connaissent pas
le chien fou quoi maintenant je
t'appelle lefranc maintenant le roi
après et maintenant et tout le monde est
devenu fou parce que tout le monde mais
qui perd
brown a bien vu
[Musique]
pas du goût de là
bon ok très bien non mais je me
débrouille avec ça
[Musique]
à m
k
non
ça veut montrer ce qu'il fait avec la
ferraille qu'il récupère en plus il
connaît bien le modèle de ma mobylette
il a la même
[Musique]
tu sais en france on essaie de trafiquer
les mobylettes pour en faire un petit
peu des choppers et tout ça oui donc ont
essayé mais on n'arrivait à rien de
comparable avec ce que tu as fait non
mais je veux dire nous on avait des
trucs on mettait des guidons tu sais
torsadé un peu chopper des selles
biplace avec un dossier on n'arrivait
jamais à faire quelque chose comme ça la
métamorphose est spectaculaire ici non
c'est pas vrai mais c'est pas vrai
incroyable
incroyable merveille des merveilles du
faso ldap incroyable un type qui réussit
à se faire une voiture c'est pas c'est
pas être appliqué une moto il sait
fabriquer une voiture mais c'est j'ai
jamais vu un engin pareil ben justement
c'est toujours la lecture
et à l écoute ou les laisse je vais
récupérer passé par là comme tu mens
comme tu ma fille en train de tarbes a
eu ses interviews des oppositions
voiture donc toi tu as réussi à
construire une voiture
à temps je fais la photo mais obligé
[Musique]
en fouillant les décharges publiques sap
s'est dégoté un visa pour l'europe comme
artistes récupérateurs
son surnom l'ambassadeur des poubelles à
chacun de ses voyages il fait la
démonstration de son talent l'art est
plus considéré par cas et en arrière par
là pour la 34e pays nul n'est prophète
en son pays ralentissement nous
maintenant on commence à être respectés
maintenant on commence à être sollicité
mes retours commencement on était permis
comme des fous ta chanson ou des noix en
tchéquie fois des ssii comme travail
et quand tu monteras certaine que tu
crois que c'est la pétitionnaire a
évolué et il commence a dit ouais du
combat ne perdez pas de me voir en
studio c'est comme ça mais est ce qu'on
mange toujours à moi un ancien mange pas
et du courage mais il faut au moins que
le croire
ouais c'est la première fois que je
monte sur un engin pareil ça c'est sûr
j'ai tout fait de l'avion de
l'hélicoptère message avait jamais fait
un drapeau américain
[Musique]
mais
là
donc l'idée c'est de partir de
ouagadougou pour aller jusqu à bobo
dioulasso
les directions sud ouest vers la côte
d'ivoire
c'est parti
allez salut les gars
très vite je quitte ouagadougou et la
pollution et déjà je respire mieux
je suis endurant plus tard
m
non
[Musique]
elles sont
justement
suite
rien
[Musique]
dryden
devant moi quatre cents kilomètres de
bitume sur la nationale 1 c'est l'une
des routes principales du burkina faso
elle sert à tout le monde et même aux
champions de la route
ah vous êtes en retard dégâts
il ya des échappées là bas
c'est un entraînement tous les jours
comme ça
ouais
c'est pas vrai tu as gagné le faso alors
t'es une star nationale
comment tu t'appelles
abdul
hu à saint lô sa voix dans tout ça roxx
ados
abdulwahab sadon
ok brasse et françois
ouais ouais françois très bien moi je
vais à bobo avec la mobylette
ouais bobo dioulasso
après une quarantaine de kilomètres
je dois quitter la route nationale pour
me rendre dans un village où se déroule
une fête des masques
dans un pays animiste comme le burkina
faso les masques comme les fétiches ont
une place très importante dans la
culture
dès l'entrée du village les tambours
résonnent
les masques danse les uns après les
autres
chaque apparition ne dure pas très
longtemps mais c'est d'une telle
intensité qu'on a l'impression qu'ils
entrent en transe
[Musique]
quand il est jeune le danseur choisi de
l'animal fétiche qui ornera son masque
il gardera toute sa vie le même
mais j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre ce
qui se passe devant moi
j'en prends plein la gueule
ça sont aussi ce son vient bien sûr son
qu'il se passe des choses à annoncer
ses formes
c'est qu'on voit là moi c'est la
première fois
ça fait un peu peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire une photo non
as-tu
[Rires]
merci ça arrive tous mais je veux pas
payer à chaque fois que je fais une
photo
j'ai dû remballer mon appareil photo et
j'ai repris la route il me reste une
bonne vingtaine de kilomètres pour
arriver à bazoulé où je dois dormir ce
soir
[Musique]
au burkina on trouve de l'essence
partout et même des mélangeurs spécial
mobylette
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de faire étape dans ce petit
village réputé pour ses traditions
[Musique]
à
et il est on arrivé parce que c'est plus
dur que ce que je pensais c'est une
chaleur incroyable je tombe en morceaux
la mobylette aussi un jour on est arrivé
bonjour françois ça va ça l'est vraiment
[Musique]
quand j'arrive dans le village il est
midi il semble endormi écrasée sous la
chaleur
c'est l'heure de la sieste et ça tombe
bien parce que moi aussi je suis crevé
je me détends un peu et après je vous
retrouve on va faire un on va faire un
petit tour du vieux h et à montrer tout
ça salut merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure
où les samoa génial
c'est combien le poulet
mais il faut ok on prend deux poulets
tout le monde appelle bazoulé le bila
des crocodiles parce que tout temps ça a
existé des crocodiles disent ils en fait
c'est sur les grands les grands-parents
les ancêtres sur les incas et adaptons
les miles pas grand jamais tu m'as fait
accompli c'est compliqué mazel non
d'accord
et autour de cette mare il ya combien de
villages c'est un seul village qu'est ce
que oui bon en fait base du lait 50 ans
d'accord et dans le canton il ya plus de
17 villages 17 villages et légendes et
17 villages ont le même rapport avec les
crocodiles nahla c'est uniquement en
fait le village de quartier bazoulé que
ce soit les femmes les enfants les vieux
tout le monde adore le côté tu dois le
tuteur du respect ou crocodile comme le
crocodile aussi doit de respect aux
autres parce que nous on suppose qu'en
fait avec eux on gagne de bonnes
récoltes on évite des épidémies dans le
village et tous ceux qui ont des
problèmes sociaux ceux qui ont des
petites maladies et ceux qui ont eu ou
n'ont pas d'enfants ils viennent auprès
de crocodiles dont c'était une occasion
pour les remercier et pour les nourrir
aussi
en fait je les chatouilles un peu ce
qu'ils aiment bien ça comme ça il est
tranquille et des eaux a pas de problème
puisque je tiens le bois est ce que je
peux le taper aussi l'ancrage de phase
iia ouais il est venu pour me voir
file en contre
bas la balle et un autre qui arrive
celui là il a entendu les cris du boulet
moi tu sais ce qui m'impressionne le
plus c'est de voir les enfants à côté je
crois que c'est ça qui m'impressionne
oui de voir les enfants qui marchent à
côté comme ça ouais ça c'est incroyable
et donc la famille là qui est là ils
habitent ici juste là où j'habite maison
qu'ils habitent au milieu des crocodiles
voilà en quelque sorte oui hein ils
viennent ils travaillent juste là et que
vous avez uniquement les briques ici
pour construire la maison allez les
enfants
alors elle est aveugle
au lit donc
moi tu veux je viens de
ouais
tu crois ouais tu vas la différence
entre les taux
voilà c'est tout
well as et moules à ses traits ccca
j'adore ça or là c'est une belle mère
elle a
été obligée de me donner une autre
information alphonse très importante ils
peuvent aller très vite les jeunes
peuvent aller vite ah oui bah non pas
dans celui là
le poulet il peut aller aussi vite le
pou li na
[Musique]
tous 1
oui oui y'a pas map
yves riou toi
tu lui dis passé derrière mais qu'ils
prennent pas part à la foulée ils ont
pas peur
c'est incroyable
sans trop mignon la
ce le fils est hérité clac en ce moment
je suis impatient d'annoncer votre
retour lille a eu beau frère il est
toujours en vie bon c'est mon habitude
entame la discussion et puis une fois il
ya de l'action on regarde puis ça suffit
quoi façon j'entends rien personne
écoute on s'en fout on n'écoute pas quoi
ah oui si on écoute
ça bon film comme voilà james bond
[Musique]
voilà beaucoup
je veux voir
je veux voir tout de suite
à bazoulé en très peu de temps je me
suis senti comme chez moi
[Musique]
ça va
bien ok très bien trop bien
thibodeau
ça fait à peine une semaine que je suis
là mais j'ai les gentils
il est temps pour moi d'aller rencontrer
le roi du village
leroy naba kiiba
je dois lui offrir un coq blanc c'est la
tradition
je crois que c'est la première fois que
je vais rencontrer un roi ah oui ah bah
écoute
quand ils viennent ici c'est pas mal
aussi comporter bien sûr on n'a pas
l'habitude doit sa majesté
genre merci de m'accueillir
à bonne date et
nicolas vivier dit qu on fait tenir
compte en fait de faire comme la
partition exactement du poulet tout
pourrait bien lui donner de l'argent
mais bien sûr je préfère donner un beau
poulet on a été chercher un poulet dans
le marché un très beau marché la
tradition veut que en fait comme ça oui
moi je donne à lui et lui transmet très
bien voila voila locaux la voilà
à la bouche
[Rires]
ce monsieur c'est le chef du protocole
c'est ça il s'occupe du protocole
d'accord ça c'est son palais ici tout
autour
c'est ici le palais la
visiter
les lentilles c'est chez lui d'accord
ici ils habitent ici en fait la maison
des trucs la maison des fétiches
d'accord et les sa famille ces femmes il
a combien de femmes le roi beaucoup de
femmes
et quelques vieilles away mais dans
l'es9 vous comptez les vieilles ou non
anne on compare les vieilles way dévié
sont les femmes ah oui les femmes de son
père d'accord d'accord d'accord combien
d'enfants
ça vaut 200 200 enfants
avait à peu près de 10 ans s'est ainsi
dit les deux sens ouais ouais lui sait
enfin ce sont des enfants dits oui oui
d'accord mou les flèches du fleuve enfin
sont désormais d'accord d'accord
abord celle là elle est allée plus âgée
que vous aimez bien les très belles et
bien elle bien conservé oui il a déjà
poursuit sa
il a déjà il a déjà tout prévu il a tout
faux
et à yassa photos adresses et non pas tu
y vas naba kiiba d'accord
ça c'est moi tout ça c'est le palais
donc c'est elle qui habite là-bas c'est
la gardienne des maisons fétiche et ça
c'est la confiance absolue c'est ça ah
oui elle est la poste le trend court est
important la spa beaucoup comme les
autres mais lula ne permet pas
et elles peuvent pas elles pour faire 5
minutes du match ah bon et elle revient
tout de suite ici pour regarder les
choses
même pas bonjour
c'est compliqué la vie au château il ya
plein de choses
[Musique]
et le pays le pays ça va ça va ça va
pourvu que ça dure les enfants viennent
tous les enfants viennent la voir alors
voilà sa petite fille qui viennent
l'aider à ça va prendre combien de temps
si on veut rencontrer tous les membres
de la famille royale il faut que je
reste ici pendant deux mois encore
je quitte alphonse le village et la
famille royale avec le sentiment d'avoir
été reçu comme un prince
j'ai beaucoup appris sur la société
mossi et ses coutumes
prochaine étape ça bout j'ai scotché le
phare de ma mob pour qu'ils résistent
aux secousses mais je ne suis pas au
bout de mes surprises
[Musique]
j'ai les avant bras brûlés et j'ai mal
aux fesses et
est
écrit qu'est-ce que je peux faire
ça y'a rien qui fera jamais que c'est
tiennent
debout
si lointain
bon il faut que je change
si ça marche c'est bon
je ne suis pas un as de la mécanique
mais j'arrive toujours à me débrouiller
une mobylette c'est si simple à réparer
et puis au pire on peut toujours la
charge est sur le toit d'une voiture
on va faire vraiment attention parce que
la route est bonne en nationale 1 elle
est très bonne mais il ya des vraiment
l'eau
et j'ai failli se faire surprendre
ce serait catastrophique
et vous
[Musique]
oh
à sabou je voulais rencontrer les
bronzier le bronze est un artisanat
traditionnel du burkina faso
et en arrivant c'est un festival de
danse qui m'attend
[Musique]
et la bière de mil ou le déjà à flot
ça continue à danser hockey vous voulez
boire et à oui je vais partager un verre
avec vous ok c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon non parce qu'après moi je
repars en mobylette ouais donc doucement
quoi doucement sur la boisson allez hop
la danse est parlante moi je l'attends
ouart va
bien d'accord le web à warba union
d'accord et son la même famille
peut-être là d'accord
jouer
voilà à moi vous voulez que je souffle
passion akhavan hockey
dans les villages c'est pas drôle c'est
pas lol
je fais ok
ok pas de problème c'est parti les gars
vous êtes prêts à danser 1 2 3
avant fait reprocher des vosges suivent
les chiffres et agathe avait
sifflé
parce que vous vous savez ce qu'ils
disent qu il y ait une signification la
dernière maintenant on va me parler en
sifflant déjà riche qu'on combat tout et
on tourne
beaucoup
[Musique]
angoulême et refit
auquel la gauche merci la droite merci
de nous lâcher tu pouvais le drame
ouvert très bien très bien très ouais
mais c'est plutôt bon que merci les gars
ouais bon merci beaucoup
au milieu de la fête les artisans
continue à travailler
toujours avec les moyens du bord on
n'est pas dans quoi au fond du temps ça
tu me dis que c'est dû mais ça c'est ça
c'est pas du monde ce conte en bas c'est
du bronze avancé il ya des bronzes là
dedans
juste est d'accord ça c'est du bronze ok
c'est pas donc maintenant a encore pour
mater et admettait le poids pour allumer
le furent cédées forme c'est les formes
traditionnelles annonces et des
scellés corps de femme les femmes
danseuses des belles femmes c'est ça ça
marche toujours ça
as tu mets ça ouais d'accord comme ça ça
va pas être très bon respirer
donc d'accord donc toi t'es tu as appris
le métier maintenant tu es en train
d'apprendre à d'autres on sait qu'on dit
si le procès est fondu roma se
maintenant à mettre les monts ici si le
puits est le grand effet
comment mais le pompon admis
samedi et il fait 40 degrés donc ça
rajoute un peu de chaleur
l'étape ensuite c'est que tu vas le
couler
dans un dans un moule à l'intérieur
d'accord et après faut casser le moule
ça fait pas ça fait pas mal au coeur de
casser un moule
à je savais qu'il y avait une étape
malheureuse là dedans il ya toujours
quelque chose qui se passe qui fend le
coeur
ou bisous
et toi tu vas rester pendant deux heures
à tourner c'est pas vrai
et les burkinabés ça les intéresse ça
aussi il achète ou c'est uniquement les
touristes pas un vrai mano burkinabaise
acer qui s'achète pour pouvoir faire la
souvenez de son ethnie comme beaucoup
n'en a pas pris 1,64 et nice avaient
essayé c'était un nouveau tube bros pont
et signé
d'accord et toi ta famille faisait déjà
ça il était déjà dans le rouge nous
valent bien régalé ma mère était une
artiste du grand mère elle nous a dit ne
pas que vous laissez de métier ça tu
disparais
a avoué là il ya eu il ya eu un petit
couac là
et un petit couac là mais ça tu vas le
réparer ça non tu arrives à l'enlever ça
ou pas pas vraiment
faut pas taper trop fort pour pas
l'abîmer quand même j'imagine
ça c'est agréable à faire un c'est le
bon moment ça
j'ai fait apparaître des femmes 1 c'est
symbolique je fais découvrir des femmes
en cassant la terre elle arrive
rien
[Musique]
le défilé commence et c'est parti pour
trois jours de fête
c'est trop pour moi
je suis déjà sur la route
[Musique]
je fais des étapes d'une cinquantaine de
kilomètres par jour je suis à mi chemin
entre ouagadougou et bobo-dioulasso
à cette vitesse j'ai le temps
d'apprécier ce qui se passe en
traversant les villages
un sourire un signe demain un hochement
de tête ou simplement un regard
[Musique]
ces bombes à moscou or
c'est génial
les gens ils font une tronche mais pas
possible en voyant là la lumière est
belle
j'ai le vent dans le dos c'est idéal
pour conduire
j'ai dit bonjour tous les cinq meilleurs
faval j'arrête pas quoi
au petit matin je pars en direction de
boromo la région des éléphants
il paraît qu'il traverse très souvent la
route
et plutôt que d'attendre leur passage
sur le bitume je préfère m'approcher de
la rivière j'entre dans le parc national
en mobylette
en évitant ainsi la location d'un 4 4
hu
moi je pensais que j'allais voir au bord
de l'eau mais sont pas là aujourd'hui
ils sont pas venus au bois de l'eau si
vous êtes intéressé aux perles dans la
foulée ouais ok ouais je te suis ça
arrive ça marche
doulaye attend va pas trop près
voilà
il arrive avril arrive aïe aïe aïe aussi
impressionnant
de 12 ouais
on entend les craquements
c'est ça qui est impressionnant
finalement c'était entendre du grosbois
à craquer il faut avec la prime à le
voir
ah ça c'est des femelles
et il y en a d'autres derrière
non je vois pas
coûtent six caches c'est qu'ils veulent
pas qu'on les embête à 30 mètres des
éléphants c'est déjà suffisamment risque
et je les laisse tranquille et je
poursuis ma route vers l'ouest
[Musique]
m
oui
à quoi
[Musique]
le 300 km depuis mon départ il est temps
faire réviser ma fidèle monture
en a pas
c'est pas
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui va le pot
silence et le silencieux est cassé et il
fait comment alors c'est quoi le bruit
c'est pas joli mais bon ça c'est pas
très grave non mais on va pas changer le
pot maintenant alors je n'aime pas les
pots est juste un petit pays comme ça
mais ça va durer combien de temps
cinq minutes tu parles regarde à voir ce
qui se passe je suis venu pour cinq
minutes et la sai effet précieux
d'accord
super ouais c'est parfait
merci mille fois
bravo
cazes
[Musique]
à
on m'a donné l'adresse d'un excellent
musicien un des meilleurs joueurs de
kora du burkina faso
il s'appelle dont bas et je me présente
directement chez lui
bonjour je cherche donc bas le musicien
c'est ici à vous pouvez l'appeler merci
[Musique]
oui
à sa lui d'en bas françois allaire
d'ambassade au hockey on chantait des
places
qu'est ce que ça vous a partie des lots
en jeu ouais bonjour ça va le grand
blessé jour nous d'abord indiqué lors du
bien arrivé d'avoir à 22
je suis un luthier proprement dit mais
la cour à la vraie cora oui ça fait
vingt et une cordes à
ça
c'est la cour a
exactement et moi je préfère la prime
verte et enfin
la femme et ses 21 enfants et j'ai
réfléchi j'ai réfléchi j'ai réfléchi
j'ai trouvé une cour à du fromage et 63
contre ça c'est la cour a superposé
je la monte de telle sorte que je puisse
apprendre
à apprendre par exemple à toi si je vais
t'apprendre moins con ça prend mais de
là dedans face à face
quand ces régates face à face et que moi
je puisse apprendre ce qu'il faut
sur un instrument de musique j'ai jamais
vu ça et des banques je peux me lancer
c'est depuis 2006 que je suis sur le
projet j'écris j'ai essayé de voir les
dessine le tout
[Musique]
ça va passer françois au françois
jp 7,1
née paris à wahdah roubaud
françois travers le monde
aux
lensois
françois braud keynote
en
françois la compléter paris c'est rapide
bon avec ma petite chanson en tête
improvisé spécialement pour moi dans la
grande tradition des griots africains je
reprends la route
je suis maintenant presque au bout de
mon voyage et j'ai prévu de me rendre
dans un dernier village avant d'arriver
à bobo dioulasso
m
oui
[Musique]
k
j'ai l'intention d'aller à koro un lieu
parait-il touristique mais depuis le
début de mon voyage je les croisais
quasiment que des burkinabé
bonjour
à mon arrivée à koro je rencontre
blandine qui essayent de gagner sa vie
comme guide à l'entrée du village elle
attend le visiteur moi c'est françois
[Musique]
eh ben
ça va
ok va pas y aller on va passer par là
d'abord
retourner prendre de l'élan
allez on recommence je vous hais ces 10
sport
et c'est parti cette fois ci c'est par
là bah ouais j'sais pas si on va aller
très loin comme ça
on sait que la cantine population des
trois médecins habitants appellent ceux
de la plaine
sur celle entre du village
avant le village de colo avec tarbes a
écrit à cause de guerre après
l'explosion donc cette poule sur potash
et qui se serait installé là pour voir
les ennemis pour ça qu'ils sont
installés sur les hauteurs
c'est une ville à deux reprises
dans cette villa joue à deux équipes de
10 à kessel et ouattara des français
musulmans dans la rue du jour la plus
pratiquée ces animaux c'était la nuit
c'était le griot qui faisait ça
à koro il vaut mieux être en forme l'eau
le bois la pierre tout est monté à dos
d'homme ou plutôt à d'autres femmes
certaines vont même à pied jusqu à bobo
dioulasso 30 km aller-retour
est tout à fait comment toi tu as un
vélo tu as une moto
non
qu'est ce que tu cherches ray comme
travail alors tu sais tu trouvé
et qu'est ce qui manque pour que tu
puisses ces moyens de transport qui
manque
c'est bien qu'il soit venu alors
françois la grande terre paris c'est
rapide
[Musique]
c'est la dernière pauline
et
[Musique]
avant tu étais
à maurice
à travers toute l'afrique
l'afrique du sud l'afrique de l'est et
doit s les voici la mobo
bobo dioulasso est la deuxième ville du
pays et c'est ici que je passe par
hasard devant l'usiné où ma mobylette a
vu le jour
[Musique]
et ici ici à quoi il ya une unité
d'assemblage ou les pièces sont
fabriquées dans quelques années c'est
une unité d'assemblage d'assemblage
maintenant nous prenons la montée à
ploemel ce pêcheur chez toujours
d'accord mais c'est qu'elle la matière
première mais les constats de la
peinture ça depuis nos serveurs soit au
mali pourquoi d'ivoire d'accord mais les
pneumatiques nous prenons ça rassure au
niveau national dans la société
burkinabé le cyclomoteur
est très important je raise important
dans toutes les familles même ceux qui y
sont véhiculées ils ont quand même un
petit deux roues à côté ça au burkina
les deux groupes ne peut pas s'en passer
c'est vraiment un produit débat national
l' usine tourne au ralenti la
concurrence chinoise est passée par là
merci beaucoup monsieur tamboura pour la
visite un bonne continuation
[Musique]
tha
j'invite espagne
c'est la fin du voyage
ma mobylette acheté d'occasion au marché
de ouagadougou a tenu toutes ses
promesses
je repense à blandine qui survit en
faisant visiter son village et aux 14 km
qui la séparent de bobo dioulasso où
elles pourraient trouver du travail
alors on avait bien besoin
[Musique]
alors sur ma mobylette toute pimpante je
retourne voir blandine avec une petite
idée derrière la tête
j'ai fini mon voyage je voulais proposer
de passer une mobylette un cyclomoteur
qu'est ce que tu en penses je te laisse
te laisse le cyclomoteur qu'est ce que
tu vas faire avec je vais enfin servez
avec bruce et j'ai pas le boulot j'ai
fait mes courses avec mais tu saurais en
tue serait utilisé ça oui c'est un
problème est ce que tu vas pouvoir
mettre de l'essence dedans parce que
c'est un peu cher quand même oui pas de
problème patrolin pas de problème et usa
va te servir oui j'avais je crois que
c'est une bonne idée pas bien très bonne
idée
[Musique]
c'est une bonne idée alors harry on va
je te laisse avec oui on
salameh mais ce nouveau conte à la
[Musique]
baisse pas la tête et mon péché ne rien
tout plaisir est pour moi
car je vois aujourd'hui pour moi
celui de marteau
aïoli draps
[Musique]